das zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live eurem ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und die geschichte die da vorgestern
abend zu uns kam und gestern im laufe
des tages sich weiterentwickelt hat die
klang wie aus einem mehr oder weniger
spannenden hollywood film fast ein
bisschen unglaubwürdig ein
passagierflugzeug auf dem weg von venus
nach athen wird über dem europäischen
luftraum über weißrussland darüber
informiert dass angeblich eine bombe an
bord sei dann kommen militärjets
diskutieren das flugzeug das dann in
minsk auf dem flughafen landet damit
aber keine bombe an bord gefunden
stattdessen wird ein blogger und
journalist der namens roman protosevich
und seine freundin festgenommen
die waren bis dahin in polen eigentlich
im mit ziele sind aus weißrussland
geflohen im letzten jahr und werden
jetzt fest gesetzt einen tag später
meldet sich gesagt daher protegé fitch
mit einem etwas merkwürdigen video sagt
es geht ihm gut und es steht quasi dass
er an den protesten letztes jahr
beteiligt gewesen sein soll
und darauf reagiert der eu was an der
ganzen geschichte dran ist wie es dazu
gekommen ist was die hintergründe sind
auch der ganzen proteste in weißrussland
das möchten wir heute besprechen mit
euch natürlich zusammen und euren fragen
und kommentaren aber auch mit unserer
korrespondentin anne gellinek in brüssel
und später noch mit einer ausgewiesenen
expertin für den weissrussischen raum
nämlich von mit olga drin dorfer die ist
an der uni bremen an der
forschungsstelle für osteuropa und für
weißrussland zuständig und wird uns
alles hoffentlich genau erklären können
aber bevor wir starten fangen wir
erstmal an mit den aktuellen
entwicklungen für becker hat ein stück
für uns
dass ihr sohn in gefahr ist wussten die
eltern von roman protosevich nun müssen
sie ihn in einem video sehen das den
oppositionellen journalisten in
gefangenschaft zeigt und in dem er
angekündigt mit den ermittlern zu
kooperieren
das sind nicht seine worte und das ist
nicht seine art zu reden
es ist klar dass er den text abliest er
wird dazu gezwungen wo man kann auch gar
nicht gestehen was ihm vorgeworfen wird
weil er keine massenunruhen organisiert
hat während der landesweiten
demonstrationen für demokratie im
letzten jahr leitet romankiewicz nicht
ein internetportal das videos und
informationen über anstehende proteste
teil
damit gerät das netzwerk ins visier von
alexander lukaschenko
der verfolgt seine kritiker brutal eu
sanktionen werden ihnen davon nicht
abbringen sind sich viele polit experten
oder oppositionelle heute einig das
problem ist ein terroristisches regime
das wahlen gefälscht hat regelmäßig die
verfassung und internationales recht
bricht in ihrem polnischen exil bangen
die eltern von romantischer savage um
das leben des 26 jährigen
ich bin mir fast sicher dass sie ihm
etwas antun werden wie sie es jetzt in
unseren körpern ständig tun und dann
sagen sie es sei ein herzinfarkt oder
ein selbstmord oder sonstwas gewesen
unterdessen gehen in belarus auch heute
die willkürlichen verhaftungen die
verurteilungen die verfolgung politisch
andersdenkender weiter und in brüssel
ist als unsere korrespondentin anne
gellinek anderes war jetzt zufällig
gestern man heute eu gipfel
die staats und regierungschefs und
chefinnen haben sich sofort beraten wie
haben die reagiert ja man kann sagen
dass diese ereignisse in minsk diese
räuberpistole den eu-gipfel geradezu
gekapert hat sie haben sich 24 stunden
danach getroffen hier in brüssel
und man muss schon sagen dass sehr viele
staats und regierungschefs und chefin
beim dorst beim reingehen in den gipfel
schon sehr empört gewesen sind
also da fiel das wort staatsterrorismus
flugzeug entführung der niederländische
premier sprach von idiotie
also da wurde sehr wurde doch ganz schön
starker tobak hier geliefert und dann
war es auch klar dass relativ schnell
eine entscheidung her musste also ich
glaube die 27 haben dann auch gesagt so
jetzt müssen wir uns irgendwie jetzt
müssen wir irgendwie eine antwort aus
denken wir können jetzt nicht
auseinander gehen und sagen wir lassen
wird schenkt oder mal machen und haben
dann eben sich sehr schnell politisch
auf ein neues sanktionspaket gegen
belarus geeinigt das heißt was ist da
konkret jetzt beschlossen worden was
wird gegen weißrussland erlassen
also es gibt schon drei sanktionspaket
da sind hauptsächlich menschen die in
lukaschenkos umgebung und die aus dem
sicherheits und justizapparat
sanktioniert worden so zu sagen die
dürfen nicht mehr einreisen in die eu
deren konten sind eingefroren worden
der kgb chef der chef des
staatsfernsehens der chef der
präsidialadministration lukaschenko
selbst sein sohn polizeichefs die sind
alle schon auf der liste jetzt bei
diesem vierten paket was man schon
vorbereitet hatte versucht man sich
jetzt auf wirtschaftsunternehmen zu
kaprizieren man will jetzt gezielt
staatsunternehmen treffen die
lukaschenko nahe stehen und die eben
geld verdienen für lukaschenkos system
es gibt noch keine listung die
bundeskanzlerin wurde in ihrer
abschlusspressekonferenz auf dem gipfel
heute gefragt ob sie denn schon sagen
könnte wen genau diese sanktionen
treffen würden da sagte sie nein das
machen jetzt erstmal fachleute die sich
angucken wen können wir da sanktionieren
was kann das bringt die außenminister
werden das sicherlich in den nächsten
tagen beraten und der auswärtige dienst
der europäischen union
das ist eben die frage was kann das
bringen das sind nicht die ersten
sanktionen die die eu gegen weißrussland
erlassen hat mir was gab es da oder was
da noch so es gibt ja schon ein
waffenembargo gegen
gegen weissrussland es gab auch schon
einige firmen die mit sicherheits und
überwachungstechnik zu tun haben die auf
den listen standen
genützt hat das alles nichts weil wir
haben sozusagen zwei probleme das eine
problem ist dass die weißrussische
wirtschaft die villa russische
wirtschaft eben sehr stark nach russland
orientiert ist und weniger stark in die
europäische union es gibt zwar ein paar
güter die die europäische union aus
russland aus weißrussland importiert
also holz und kali und dünger und solche
sachen
aber das sind eben im grunde ziemlich
geringe margen die star betrifft und das
zweite ist dass lukaschenko eben von
russland und von putin komplett
finanziert wird das geht so weit dass
putin sicherheitsleute geschickt hat als
die demonstrationen als es darum ging
die demonstrationen niederzuschlagen
dass journalisten geschickt hat und auf
dem motto jetzt machen wir mal richtig
staatsfernsehen hier wir zeigen euch mal
wie das geht
also lukaschenko wird sehr stark aus
russland finanziert unterstützt
ideologisch und finanziell
und da können die eu sanktionen im
grunde nur nadelstiche seien die
vermutlich keine besonders großen
auswirkungen haben aber es geht um die
symbolwirkung es geht darum zu sagen was
man auf lukaschenka so kannst du das so
kannst du mit einem flugzeug was
zwischen zwei eu-hauptstädten mit 170 eu
bürgern an bord so kannst du mit einem
flugzeug nicht umgehen du kannst das
nicht einfach mit einer bombendrohung in
minsk landen lassen und dann leute
festnehmen
das ist die botschaft von diesen neuen
sanktionen ich habe jetzt viele
kommentare an die ziemlich hart mit der
eu ins gericht gehen und quasi sagen
also sorry ist ja nett was er da
versucht aber das bringt alles nichts
also von aids schreibt irgendwie ich das
gefühl dass sich europa gar nicht wehren
kann
internationale flüge werden entführt
personen getötet entführt und vergiftet
dass in anspielungen jetzt auf die
fälle aus russland darunter schreibt
däke sanktionen ding gar nichts der hat
genug geld das juckt den überhaupt nicht
oder hier zeno park europa nato sind
zahnlos seit ich denken kann kommt aus
europa nur ein statement
wir verurteilen diese taten auf das
schärfste und dann gibt es noch ein paar
sanktionen und mehr kommt dann die woran
liegt das eine das europa quasi gegen
solche machtspielchen und auch gegen
solche absolut undemokratischen
maßnahmen komplett machtlos zu sein
scheint natürlich daran dass europa eine
soft power ist dass europa ein
demokratisches gefüge von staaten ist
die alle demokratische chefs haben und
dass natürlich die maßnahmen die man
jetzt so was was was wären die
alternativen europa kann ja nicht in
belarus einmarschieren und sagen wir
setzen jetzt herrn lukaschenko ab oder
oder lukaschenkos residenz
bombardieren oder körpern das sind eben
keine mittel die europa zur verfügung
hat europa hat nur das mittel der
überzeugung des dialogs von sanktionen
die kommissionspräsidentin ursula von
der leyen hat heute versucht mit
zuckerbrot und gesagt wir haben ein
schönes wirtschaftspaket für belarus von
drei milliarden euro insgesamt das
würden wir sofort anschieben wenn es
denn eine demokratische entwicklung in
belarus gebe und wenn lukaschenko nicht
mehr da wäre aber das nützt natürlich
überhaupt nichts die user haben recht
natürlich hat europa ganz wenig
einflussmöglichkeiten und ich habe es
vorhin schon gesagt eine wirtschaft die
eigentlich sich nach russland richtet
und nicht in die eu die kann man eben
auch relativ schlecht sanktionieren
was europa bleibt wäre natürlich die
beziehungen zu russland zu überdenken
denn natürlich gibt es noch keine
handfesten beweis dass wladimir putin
von dieser aktion informiert war oder
sie womöglich sogar mit geheimagenten
unterstützt hat auch danach wurden die
kanzlerin heute gefragt und hat gesagt
sie habe dafür keine belege aber das
werde man sicherlich noch mal versuchen
rauszukriegen
und natürlich wird man mit putin darüber
reden müssen aber die frage ist eben
auch und da ist die europäische union
wirklich noch am anfang wie kann ein
verhältnis zu diesem sich immer
autoritärer gerierenden russland
aussehen und doch da gibt es noch keine
antwort darauf woher geht das jetzt
wirklich im chat teilweise sehr
drastische vorschläge was getan werden
sollte die werde ich das lieber nichts
weiter geben sonst machen wir uns sicher
eventuell strafbar aber hier gibt es zum
beispiel den falschen den vorschlag man
sollte in europa jegliche lukaschenko
regime mitglieder verhaften und seriöse
maßnahmen treffen ich weiß nicht ganz
genau was du damit meinst du aber
zumindest der vorschlag ja mitglieder
des regimes zu verhaften
da ist die frage ist überhaupt bekannt
ob es solche mitglieder gibt und b wäre
das überhaupt ja legitim und legal
ja ich glaube
das kann ja nur diplomaten sein wie hier
in der eu unterwegs sind belarussische
ripploh marten oder geschäftsleute dass
das sind halt alles maßnahmen die die
nicht der europäischen union entsprechen
die europäische union versucht sich
gelingt auch nicht immer sich an recht
und gesetz zu halten und an
demokratische maßstäbe und da gibt es
eben nicht wir verhaften jemanden und
setzten den fest und biss ihr bisher
roman protosevich wieder freilässt das
sind ja keine maßnahmen wie ein
demokratischer staat treffen kann ja und
insofern ist es richtig dass europa sehr
wenig einflussmöglichkeiten hat
sicherlich sollte europa noch mal
versuchen auf putin einzuwirken
angela merkel hat heute gesagt beim
nächsten gespräch mit putin dass ich
sicher bald haben werde werde ich ihnen
natürlich darauf ansprechen auf diese
geschichte in mainz aber fakt ist dass
natürlich auch putin eigentlich der
gewinner dieser geschichte ist denn der
sitzt jetzt in moskau reibt sich die
hände und sagt ihnen lukaschenko den
habe ich jetzt noch fester in meiner
hand die ganze woche hat eine frage die
habe ich gedacht könnten wir auch frau
gründer war fragen aber da du ja auch
korrespondent in moskau lange zeit
gewesen bist kannst du sie auch
vielleicht beantworten nämlich die frage
was hat brust band eigentlich davon sich
mit weißrussland zu verbünden und das
land so eng an sich zu binden
russland hat davon erstmal
geostrategisch das ist ein puffer hat
zwischen der eu dem baltikum und sich
sein im eigenen land also die die bilder
belarus ist ein sehr schöner cordon
sanitaire sozusagen mit dem sich
russland schützen kann
außerdem ist russland ja ein land was
nicht mehr so schrecklich viele
verbündete in der welt hat belarus
finanziert putin komplett und insofern
ist lukaschenko voll von ihm abhängig
außerdem gibt es diese idee eines
bundesstaates dass man russland und
weißrussland zu einem land zusammen
fügen will das ist eine idee die ist
schon glaube fast 15 20 jahre alt sie
wird nie richtig weiterentwickelt weil
mal putin nicht so richtig dafür ist mal
lukaschenko nicht so richtig dafür
aber offenbar benutzt die beiden
benutzten sich gegenseitig lukas
schenkel braucht putin weil er sonst
bankrott wäre die die bilder russische
wirtschaft kann ohne infusionen aus dem
von russland überhaupt nicht überleben
und putin braucht lukaschenko als
verbündeten als jemanden der der ihn
sozusagen vor dem westen und der nato da
in einem blog setzt er kann da
sicherlich wird er sicherlich auch atom
oder oder waffen stationiert haben in
belarus insofern ist das eine für beide
günstige günstige beziehung also hier
geht es noch ein paar anmerkungen dass
die amerikaner das auch mal mit adwords
snowden versucht hätten also quasi ein
ein ähnliches vorhaben das war 2013
kannst du das noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen und würdest du sagen dass
es tatsächlich ein ähnlicher fall
gewesen ist
also da ging es um das
regierungsflugzeug des bolivianischen
präsidenten glaube ich evo morales der
ich weiß nicht mehr von wo aber nach und
moskau floss mit seiner
regierungsmaschine und moskau genau und
es gab den verdacht dass edward snowden
der wiederum von den amerikanern gesucht
wurde als whistleblower an bord sein
könnte um eben ausgeflogen zu werden in
ein bolivianisches exil
und dann wurde diese maschine in wien
musste sie notlanden weil die
verschiedene europäische regierung
gesagt haben wir lassen sich nicht durch
fliegen und du musst jetzt hier landen
die maschine wurde untersucht etwas
boden war wie wir wissen nicht an bord
ja die geschichte ist irgendwie ähnlich
und irgendwie auch nicht ähnlich weil es
handelt sich um ein regierung hat sich
um ein regierungsflugzeug gehandelt und
für regierungsflugzeuge gelten habe ich
auch erst jetzt gelernt andere regeln
als für passagierflugzeuge
regierungsflugzeuge dürfen nie ohne
genehmigung durch irgendeinen luftraum
fliegen sondern die müssen immer vorher
ankündigen
der bolivianische präsident fliege jetzt
von moskau nach wien und dann müssen
alle
der sukzessive genehmigung erteilen für
den luftraum
das ist bei passagierflugzeugen und umso
eines ging es ja in dem minsker fall
etwas anderes weil da gibt es dauer
genehmigungen sozusagen überflugrechte
werden gebühren gezahlt an in dem fall
belarus dass man darüber pflicht und es
gibt da andere regeln und eigentlich ist
es bei passagierflugzeugen eben nicht
möglich diese überfluggenehmigung nicht
zu erteilen oder gar den flug
abzubrechen so wie es hier in linz
geschehen ist das geht nur bei
terrorverdacht und dieses genau das hat
er hat haben die haben die belarussen
sich jetzt zunutze gemacht und eben
diese diese bombendrohung konstruiert
dies offenbar nicht gab also es ist
irgendwie vergleichbar aber irgendwie
auch nicht
also auf jeden fall ein doch relativ
einmaliger vorfall der dort vor gestern
stattgefunden hat mit ganz klaren
konsequenzen aus der eu aber hier im
chat sind sich viele einig ein zahnloser
tiger und ja man könnte mehr machen
allerdings eure ideen sind teilweise
auch finde ich ein bisschen schwierig
muss ich sagen andere vielen dank für
deine einschätzungen und für die
aktuelle berichterstattung und wir
gucken dass erstmal an die das mit der
opposition in belarus eigentlich läuft
denn das ist schon etwas länger ein
ziemlich schwieriger job dort gegen den
amtierenden präsidenten und machthaber
manche nennen ihn diktator fortzugehen
wer es trotzdem tut lebt teilweise
wirklich gefährlich und muss ins
polnische exil auswandern das ist
letztes jahr schon mehrfach passiert und
meine kollegin natalie steger hat dort
ein paar exilanten für uns getroffen
es ist ein schrei der verzweiflung der
wut des entsetzens in warschau
demonstrieren exil bella russen
aktivisten der opposition des regimes in
minsk
lasst uns alle zusammen schreien für
jeden der nicht mehr bei uns ist für
jeden der jetzt leidet für familien
getrennt wurden
auch freunde und kollegen des
festgenommenen roman botta service sind
dabei hier in warschau und im
litauischen vilnius wohnte der blogger
des portals nektar geflohen aus belarus
wie er mit roman wurden als die personen
nummer eins eingestuft in verbindung mit
terrorismus und dafür droht uns
natürlich die todesstrafe in belarus
funktionäre die regierung sagen sie
werden uns bekämpfen
die letzten proben für die
hauptnachrichtensendung von bell zeit in
warschau einem fernsehsender für belarus
als alternative zum bälle russischen
staatsfernsehen
der aufmacher klar seit sonntag haben
sie hier keine ruhige minute
das ist zu dieser situation kommt in der
lukaschenko minsk eigene bürger
terrorisiert aber nur noch beginnt die
ganze welt zu terrorisieren
eine entführung eines zivilen flugzeugs
niemand konnte sich vorstellen dass so
etwas möglich ist
mehr als 70 leute arbeiten in warschau
für wels hat betrieben vom polnischen
fernsehen aber auch andere eu länder
unterstützen das projekt als
gegengewicht zur medialen
propagandamaschine von machthaber lukasz
in dieser situation denke ich dass der
kreml und minsk eng zusammenarbeiten mit
dem anliegen alles was frei ist zu
ersticken
natürlich ging es mir durch den kopf
gefallen dass sie mich in einen
kofferraum packen und irgendwohin weg
bringen
aus ihrem exil in villen news meldete
sich heute wieder svetlana die an oskar
lukaschenko regime ist eine gefahr für
regionale und europäische sicherheit
die einzige lösung dieser krise sind
freie und faire wahlen und demokratische
reformen
die belarussische opposition im ausland
ohnehin in sorge ist nach der verhaftung
in minsk hochgradig alarmiert
einschüchtern lassen aber wollen sie
sich hier bei beltz hat jedenfalls nicht
ja also weißrussland ist seit letztem
jahr in den schlagzeilen viele wussten
bis dahin gar nicht wo das land genau
ist aber jetzt ist es wichtig ruhe zu
sprechen und auch noch mal vielleicht
darüber zu reden was dort eigentlich
genau los ist was hinter den protesten
steckt und hinter dieser verhaftung das
tue ich jetzt mit einer ausgewiesenen
expertin mit olga drinnen dorfer
universität bremen forschungsstelle
osteuropa und dort zuständig für belarus
hannover hat sie diese aktion der
weißrussischen regierung überrascht ja
schockierte sogar also ich muss auch
ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich schon seit
august 2020 ungefähr bewahrte war
eigentlich der boden ist also fahren der
boden erreicht werden kann der boden der
repressionen in belarus auch als person
den berufs aufgewachsen ist in einer
autokratie habe ich so was wirklich
nicht erwartet da hat mir einfach in der
fantasie gefällt und vor allem weil ich
auch nicht verstanden habe inwieweit es
überhaupt angemessen ist diese eine
person zu nehmen zu verhaften und dafür
eine reihe von politischen
wirtschaftlichen folgen zu haben das ja
auch irgendwie vorhersehbar war also das
hätte man sich denken können
dazu ist führen könnte das scheint mir
entweder eine sehr emotionale
entscheidung zu sein oder was ich nicht
bestätigen kann was man allerdings auch
nicht ausschließen kann dass tatsächlich
und das bestätigt das was die kollegen
auslosung gesagt hat das ist eben auch
sondern bestimmten vielleicht
zusammenarbeit zwischen den russischen
russischen geheimdiensten der ball
gekommen ist es gibt hier genau die
frage von aki auf youtube warum ist
dieser blogger so interessant für
lukaschenko also das was ist das
vielleicht auch für eine symbolwirkung
ins land hinein
das ist glaube ich weniger ein symbol
sondern tatsächlich was also irgendwas
was auch in der realität gefährlich war
und zwar mindestens august bis oktober
man war mitbegründer oder ist immer noch
mitbegründer von einem integral kanal
nicht kann und über dieses medium
hunderttausenden belanglosen jede woche
dazu aufgerufen auf den straßen zu
protestieren und dass das ist auch so
was was zum ersten mal in der russischen
geschichte passiert ist dass man eben
durch online medien geführt dass soziale
medien solche wahnsinnig große massen
menschen mobilisiert hat mobilisieren
konnte und deshalb auch wirklich keiner
erwartet und das aber wie gesagt damals
wichtig heutzutage sehen wir diese
100.000 menschen nicht mehr auf den
straßen
deswegen also praktisch gesehen bega
wirklich nicht transparent gewesen ist
beziehungsweise klar man kann den mensch
leider foltern und wir haben ja schon
das video gesehen wird jetzt auch nicht
mehr so sind aus dem bruder fürst
wahrscheinlich gefahren um irgendwelche
informationen aus ihm raus zu ziehen
das ist wohl auch der punkt gewesen
leider traten die situation für
oppositionelle und journalisten oder für
blogger die versucht haben frei zu
berichten immer schon so gefährlich in
belarus oder hat sich das im laufe des
letzten jahres zugespitzt hat sich
dramatisch zugespitzt also wie gesagt
das war ja auch schon seit 26 jahren wir
haben mit einer autokratie zu tun aber
auch innerhalb von dieser auto kritik
gab es sowas wie informelle regeln wie
zum beispiel wenn man sich jetzt nicht
so sehr politisch engagiert wenn man
sage ich mal einfachen bürger ist oder
bürgerinnen dann hat man auch sein
eigenes normales leben also die
depressionen die haben dann immer eher
oppositionsparteien betroffen oder auch
aus deswegen die organisationen die sich
politisch engagiert hatten und auch
unabhängige medien gab es in belarus
mehrere online-medien es gab sogar so
eine zeit wo man auch printmedien um
mich staatliche printmedien überall
kaufen konnte ich meine auch bei den
autokratien gibt haben sozusagen
unterschiedliche ebenen
fotografieren ja und das was wir jetzt
sehen ist einfach so ein polizeistaat
das ist auch für belarus neu und das ist
auch was das wichtigste was die
situation von situation früher von den
fördern waren unterscheidet ist dass es
jetzt tatsächlich eine autokratie der
minderheit ist das sogar schon für nicht
mehr die mehrheit in der bevölkerung hat
das ist aus dem ersten mal passiert und
das haben die menschen auch zum ersten
mal verstand die haben zum ersten mal
das gefühl bekommen letztes jahr
wir gehören zur mehrheit und wir sind
eine proteststimmen protestbewegung und
uns gibt es mehr als einen anderen dass
das ist dieses gefühl gibt es in belarus
das sieht man das will man nun sieht man
dass sie visuell auf den straßen nicht
mehr weil der preis der politischen
beteiligung jetzt unangemessen hoch ist
für die menschen
wer hat sich denn an diesen protesten
beteiligt es waren teilweise 200.000
menschen gleichzeitig auf den straßen
von minz zu den hochzeiten des protests
trotzdem wurden ja in weißrussland noch
sehr viel mehr menschen also wer war das
genau wer da auf die straße gegangen ist
waren das vor allem die alten vor allem
die jungen werden dass vor allem die gut
vernetzen
die menschen vom land also denn es gibt
jetzt momentan schon die ersten umfragen
oder auch so vor ort umfragen als es
noch möglich war der protest beim
menschen um zu fragen nach haben
russische soziologen sind projekt
durchgeführt und es gab seitdem auch
mehrere online umfragen auf
unterschiedlichen situationen auch von
deutschland aus
diese umfragen zeigten dass es wirklich
eine volksbewegung geworden ist dass da
wirklich sehr unterschiedliche schichten
der gesellschaft vertreten waren seien
studenten als erstes ist auch
mitarbeiter um oder arbeite also beiden
staatlichen unternehmen natürlich auch
um menschen aus dem business aber auch
sage ich mal ganz normale menschen die
einfach bürger sind und sich niemals
dafür politisch engagiert hatten und das
was schon dass er auch der wichtigste
unterschied zu allen protesten
nach protesten davor weil die meisten
jahr bis zu ein paar tage gedauert
hatten und das war 2006 2010 hatten wir
das schon und das ohne protest sind
wirklich ein halbes jahr so august bis
dezember dauern kann in belarus das war
für mich auch eine große überraschung
auch für die menschen die da draußen
waren auf den straßen wir haben
plötzlich verstand dass sich die
gesellschaft in all diesen jahren der
autokratie tatsächlich verändert hat es
geht ja um die veränderung der
politischen kultur dass die menschen so
zu sagen vielleicht viel weiter sind als
der lukaschenka selbst der seit 94 ende
macht ist und immer noch relativ ähnlich
denkt wie er damals gedacht hat als etwa
der ecke mehrheit bekommen hat eine
frage die ich mir gestellt habe die sich
auch hier user im stream stellen wenn
man sich angeguckt hat wie das letztes
jahr teilweise auch mit hilfe der armee
und der polizei niedergeknüppelt wurde
teilweise auch mit scharfer munition
geschossen wurde auf den straßen
dann fragt man sich schon warum haben
die sicherheitskräfte das mitgemacht und
sich nicht den protesten angeschlossen
möchte zum beispiel maxi king auch
wissen können sie das beantworten also
woran liegt das dass dann tatsächlich so
ein großer militär und sicherheits und
und polizeiapparat bereit ist auf das
eigene volk zu schießen und auch so hart
mit den umzugehen
ich kann die frage nachvollziehen
allerdings habe ich mir die frage etwas
anderes gestellt also die tatsache dass
sicherheitskräfte und polizei und so
weiter die ja eigentlich seit jahren
dafür geschult wurden
das zu machen hat mich eher nicht
überrascht was mich eher überrascht hat
also noch mal die antwort das ist ihre
arbeit sie wohnen geschult sie haben
auch wir leben auch nur zu sagen
ideologisch gesehen mit dass eine andere
welt dass die die der este bürger und
sie werden auch gut bezahlt das vor was
mich eher überrascht hat ist das
sozusagen die die menschen die schon
staatlichen im ministerien arbeiten oder
auf ebenen lokal verwalten dass in dem
menschen bin ich seit jahren so brutal
geschult werden
menschen mit bürger zu schlagen dass sie
eben auch passte nicht reagiert es gab
nur ein einzige fall im grödner das ist
im westen von belarus in der diele also
die idee stets verwalten und wird
versucht hat mit menschen kontakt zu
kommen und zu sprechen
die person wurde aber sofort gewechselt
und hatte in seiner arbeit verloren und
das wurde dann nicht verbreitet und ja
man spricht den bernerhof über
sogenannten das heißt nennt sich macht
vertikal geht ja darum dass alle
menschen eben weniger kohle sind alle
kontakte haben auch innerhalb des
systems und vielmehr und vertikale
kontakte bis auf zu lukaschenka selbst
und dass sich dieses system auf angst
und loyalität
seit mehreren jahren gebildet hat und
wir haben im august gesehen wie gut dass
sich aufgebaut hat wird gut es
funktioniert hat das ist wirklich eine
stabile und stabiles autokratisches
system einer ziemlich konsolidierte
autokratie ist quasi das denken aus aus
den alten sowjet-zeiten also das von
oben nach unten durch regiert wird und
dass man zu gehorchen hat und dass es
quasi keine keine breite demokratische
basis gibt es die zusammen entscheidet
und dass lukas schenkel versucht das
quasi noch so zu handhaben wie damals ja
das ist genau ja dass es genau das
modell das von der sowjetunion
übernommen wurde
allerdings müssen wir auch zugeben dass
ganz viele menschen belarus damals
wirklich hin abgestimmt hatten und
dieses system auch unterstützt hatten
weil sie angst vor den zerfall der
sowjetunion hatten weil sie ganz viel
den menschen - nicht wussten was sie mit
dieser unabhängigkeit machen sollten
und die generation die jetzt auf den
straßen sind das ist natürlich anderen
generationen das ist eine globalisierte
generation ist eine generation die
freundschaften aus man hat zugang zu
internet medien
auch wenn bella russische onlinemedien
blockiert werden können sie auf englisch
lesen und so weiter und so fort da sind
einfach andere menschen und
dementsprechen man gefühlt ist dass das
system ist einfach nicht versteht also
der stadt hat überhaupt nicht verstanden
sie haben diese veränderung phase der
politischen kultur in burgers komplett
verpasst wie haben es verpasst die
richtigen die online medien und sozialen
medien geworden sind und die waren
entscheidend letztes jahr für die
mobilisierung der belassen
und das ist nicht mehr rückwirkend zu
tun also man kann die menschen schlagen
aber man kann sie sind denkt weiter
nicht mehr
das wird nicht so kommen interessante
frage von tofu burger auf youtube der
möchte oder die möchte gerne wissen wie
diese geschichte jetzt die gerade
passiert ist in belarus in weißrussland
verkauft wird oder wird die
totgeschwiegen und und mich weiter
thematisiert doch natürlich des verkaufs
sozusagen also es gibt durchaus
staatliche medien
die versuchen schon den fokus darauf zu
setzen dass da angeblich doch eine bombe
gewesen ist und das lokal scheint konnte
ganze stadt alles gemacht haben um die
eu bürger dadurch zu retten und aber wie
viel prozent der bevölkerung wirklich
daran glaubt das ist glaube ich eine
rhetorische frage also natürlich ist als
sie sich einfach nicht schlecht aus es
ist ein der sehen menschen dass da
irgendwas nicht stimmt und spätestens
nach dem mann verhaftet oder weiß einem
klar war da ein bisschen grundbuch jetzt
ist es ja so wenn man sich die
geschichte anguckt von belarus sind
verhältnis zu russland und zur eu habe
ich gelernt dass es lange zeit quasi den
versuch gab von lukaschenko quasi
zwischen den seiten zu bleiben also sich
nicht klar für eine westliche seite und
nicht klar für eine russische seite zu
entscheiden wie ist es dazu gekommen
dass das land und vor allem er als
machthaber hat jetzt doch auf die seite
von russland und von mutigen gewechselt
zu haben scheinen daher ist es dazu
gekommen
dadurch dass die ganzen demonstranten in
einem im august so brutal auf sie bella
sogar brutal geschlagen wurden und ein
bisschen dass es mehrere tausend folter
felder gibt und es gibt auch todesfälle
was ja auch noch nie bei den protesten
belarus passiert ist
die protestierenden geschossen wurden
und die ganze region die aus dem westen
kam hat es dann auch nicht mehr möglich
gemacht dass eine weitere annäherung
zwischen belarus und sich
weiterentwickelt wie wir das in den
letzten fünf jahren gesehen haben also
sie haben schon recht das war schon
immer so
theoretisch wäre es möglich dass es
wieder dazu kommt wobei ich mir die
situation nicht mehr vorstellen kann was
da was zu einer deeskalation beitragen
könnte also bis jetzt haben wir nur eine
eskalation gesehen also seit ende august
und ende oktober november ungefähr gibt
es immer wieder neue repressionswelle
ein paar tage vor dem fall flugzeug
hatten wir schließung des größten
nachrichtenportals unabhängige
nachrichtenportal stone beinwell davos
das ist in riesigen schlag gegen
unabhängiger journalismus und so weiter
und so fort also diese welle wird immer
noch größere ich frage mich auch wenn es
dann wieder so ein heim kommt aber er
hat momentan sieht es für mich nicht
weil ich geschaut
ja und das bedeutet gleichzeitig das
natürlich der der einzige ausweg aus
russland bleibt und es ist immer noch
viel mehr als noch wo ich jetzt durch
die situation durch die politische krise
der staat legt sowohl wirtschaftlich als
auch politisch von russland abhängig
hier gibt es zwei konkrete fragen einmal
von bubi ob die bevölkerung gerade
weiter auf die straße geht
ich glaube dass es so in dem sinne wie
wir das im sommer hatten gerade nicht
der fall
nein in solchen maßstäben auf keinen
fall also was man noch versucht hat so
ende 2020 an anfang dieses jahr diese
lokale protesten also vor den eigenen
häusern zu organisieren oder eben
kleineren gruppen einfach durch die
straßen zu laufen und bleibt das wird
jetzt von vom staat nicht mehr toleriert
also es kommt wirklich zu grotesk robben
der repression in dem man ja da
verurteilt wird indem man weiß rot weiße
socken trägt zum beispiel diese dieser
für deutschland
das reicht schon oder in der man sich
unterhalten einen chatten telegramm zu
kritischen politisch
fragen das also wirklich gern seerosen
und nie gesehen ist auch schon eine
autokratie aber autokratien können ja
auch unterschiedlich seinen menschen
haben jetzt angst einfach alles zu tun
alles was vom staat als politisch
gesehen werk könnte und ich frage mich
ob sie überhaupt dann nochmal die die
mut haben zudem sind lokalwahlen
vorgesehen ende des jahres oder anfang
2012 sie sich zutrauen würden also ich
kenne auch persönlich menschen die
halbes jahr protestiert hatten
um sich jetzt in der migration überlegen
weil sie es einfach riesig physisch
nicht mehr sicher sie in die ganze
situation einfach wenn man auch noch
nichts macht man kann einfach durch die
straße laufen und sich am falschen ort
zur falschen zeit hin und reiß genommen
sein das ist das waren noch nie so sogar
mag ich also da sind ja auch viele schon
nach polen ausgewandert haben gerade
gesehen eine konkrete frage hier noch
von ikarus die organisiert und
informiert sich die opposition gibt es
da noch freie medien oder ist die
opposition muss man das jetzt
feststellen quasi zerschlagen worden
gut also ich würde schon klebt die
sachen unterscheiden opposition oder
sogar drei sachen also es gab es früher
diese klassische partei opposition ja in
badehosen die ja nicht wirklich breit so
populär oder irgendwie bekannt in der
bevölkerung war und was ihr letztes jahr
gesehen haben wir was anderes es war die
sogenannte neue opposition das waren ja
menschen aus den eliten außen
staatssystem die ehemalige die jetzt ja
auch verhaftet sind und dann gab es die
hamas könnte sich überhaupt als hausfrau
positioniert hatte und eigentlich durch
zufall in die politik gekommen ist und
wieso das ganze passiert ist weil die
gesellschaften sehr froh proteststimmen
hatte also es ist nicht so dass jetzt
unbedingt alle sieger noch präsidentin
gesehen hatten
sondern sie haben wie ich gegen noch was
schenken
es gibt auch unabhängige oder nicht
staatlichen medien die ja nicht
unbedingt was mit der opposition zu tun
haben wir sind einfach ganz normale
journalismus was wir hier in deutschland
haben komplett zu schlagen sind sie noch
nicht aber wie gesagt das was mit bypass
jetzt ist das ist schon ziemlich
einzigartig und das wird natürlich auch
folgen haben ja dass die menschen und
wer da dann vielleicht in den sozialen
medien die nachrichten lesen sind
das spricht man auch nicht immer über
professionelle journalisten ja dort der
wind information auch nicht gecheckt
oder eben dass die russischen medien
noch mehr einfluss in bella russischen
informationsraum bekommen dass dadurch
auch in negativer folgen für das land so
jetzt noch eine frage sie haben ja schon
gesagt sie haben wenig hofft nun dass
tatsächlich jetzt viel sich ändert sie
fragen sich wie lange aber das noch geht
war fabian schubert möchte ja noch mal
wissen was meinen sie
wie kann man lukas schenkel schaden
damit endlich nach gibt gerade kam auch
die meldung dass es großbritannien
seinen luftraum gesperrt hat für
flugzeuge aus weißrussland und dort
niemanden der lampen und über fliegen
darf
haben sie eine ahnung gibt es überhaupt
ein druckmittel an der gag unsere
brüssel korrespondentin war ja doch sehr
skeptisch dass die sanktionen die
verhängt wurden überhaupt was bringen
können naja das ist eine frage der frage
gibt es glaube ich auch keine richtige
antwort ja also man versucht einfach das
was eben jetzt möglich ist in dieser
zeit mit diesem mittel video hat sei usa
oder großbritannien
es werden natürlich zu wirtschaftlichen
schaden kommen wenn es tatsächlich dann
so sein dass wir mal wie er das baby der
russischen fluggesellschaft linke
überhaupt nicht über die oder in die eu
fliegen können oder dass eben über
bilder bus überhaupt nicht geflogen wird
von der eu ob es denn dazu führt dass
die präsident zurücktreten natürlich
nicht also man kann ja auch breite
wirtschafts funktionen funktionen
tschuldigung beschließen gegen mehrere
unternehmen die ja irgendwie mit dem
team zusammenarbeiten und mehreren
oppositionskräfte
ja es ziemlich auch dafür dass auch
staatsunternehmen große staatliche
fabriken die man auch aus um zu
lebzeiten beide russ hat das auch die
funktioniert werden aber auch dazu gibt
es keine eindeutige meinung oder eine
meinung die eine richtige meinung auch
inhalte der depeschen expertenkreise
oder innerhalb der bevölkerung weil es
natürlich auch bedeuten könnte dass
viele menschen ihre arbeitsplätze
verlieren also man kann schon
unterschiedliche mechanismen
ausprobieren wie gesagt man soll nicht
damit rechnen dass das so trägt kommt in
die sofort weil wie gesagt also diese
menschen jetzt macht er geht es ja
eigentlich um psychische und physische
überleben um ihre persönliche physische
sicherheit und wenn es nicht
gewährleistet wird jetzt momentan wird
es nicht gewährleistete ist ein
lukaschenka heute zurücktreten würde
er wird sich schon gedanken machen was
passiert mit dem natürlich also der hat
angst deswegen auch nicht gehen angst
ist ja sehr sehr wichtiger motivator an
ihnen der meditation eine situation die
wir so auch aus anderen ländern schon
kennen wo sie manchmal gut manchmal
nicht so gut geht ist hier höre ich
skepsis bei ihnen vor in dover danke für
ihre antworten wir werden dranbleiben
und hoffen wir dass ich das irgendwie
doch noch friedlich regelt aber
natürlich wir können nicht in die
zukunft schauen
der hatte für euch weiter berichten hat
für heute machen aber schluss heute.de
wahrsagen an strom sage ich jetzt stehst
du euch vielen dank für eure ganzen
fragen und für eure kommentare und ich
sage bis zum nächsten live stehen dann
macht's gut dass dann